reality is not a straight line  every passing moment is a chance for a  new offshoot  a new variation in fact there are more  realities than you can possibly fathom  an infinite number of what is i'm  jeffrey wright and as the voice of the  watcher in marvel's what if i can see  what few others can  the totality of the multiverse across  all time and space  the stories you thought you knew are  nothing like you remember  familiar faces who are you  in unfamiliar roles  [Music]  the captain women aren't soldiers i  would get ready agent carter  no one expected  foes who became friends  uh wow i did not see that coming  what if the stories you remember changed  in a way  you'd never forget t'challa  what if the heroes you knew became  something  larger than life on august 11th  expect the unexpected  that's weird and ask yourself the  question  what if streaming august 11th  only on disney plus  you